-Hey, Demetrius,
how have you been spending
your nights lately?
-I sure have.
-I asked you how, not if.
-Oh, yeah, it's that time,
alright.
-I guess it is time
to sing about something
that's very important to us.
-[ Vocalizes ]
[ Vocalizes ]
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
♪♪
-♪ Been a long week
and it's time to set the mood ♪
-♪ With candles
and bubbly wubbly ♪
♪ And a big-ass plate of food ♪
-♪ My tummy's rumbling ♪
♪ And it's almost time to eat ♪
-♪ To sit on down and dig right
in with the best company ♪
-♪ But then I remember ♪
-♪ What you remember? ♪
-♪ There's no one home ♪
-♪ I'm eating alone ♪
-♪ So I do what I always do ♪
♪ And open YouTube on my phone ♪
-♪ Eating alone so I have to
watch YouTube ♪
♪ Can't stand the silence,
got to YouTube ♪
-♪ It's not sad, there's just
no one here to talk to ♪
♪ Scat, scooby-dooby,
dooby-doo, YouTube, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah, YouTube, yeah ♪
♪ Food and some YouTube ♪
♪ All I need is me
and food and YouTube, yeah ♪
♪♪
-♪ I'm eating pasta ♪
♪ Watching someone make
a lobster bisque ♪
-♪ And me, I'm watching people
poppin' pimples ♪
♪ Or a random Joe Rogan clip ♪
-Joe Rogan?
♪ I try eating without it ♪
[ Crickets chirping ]
♪ And I'm never doing that
again ♪
-♪ And as for me ♪
♪ I've been pairing
all my meals ♪
♪ With amateur documentaries ♪
♪ That prove that the deep state
is real ♪
-♪ Wait, that's a really bad
rabbit hole ♪
-♪ Well, if it is,
then let me fall ♪
-♪ I need YouTube to eat
and eating to live ♪
-♪ And I feel nothing at all ♪
-Wait, Demetrius.
I'm getting concerned about
the content you're watching
vis-a-vis YouTube.
-How so?
I feel better than anybody on
this flat Earth.
-See, that verbiage
is scary to me.
-No, what's scary is the snake
DNA the Rothschilds put into
the vaccine
to control your mind.
-Oh, no.
-Did you know
George Washington's
real name is Malcolm X?
-That's just not true.
How the hell is your algorithm
giving you this?
-Let's ask ourselves.
-Ladies and gentlemen,
The Algorithm.
-♪ I am The Algorithm
and I'm here to help ♪
♪ Bitch, I know you better
than you know yourself ♪
♪ Oh, you watch travel vids? ♪
♪ I can show you the world ♪
♪ Here's the 10 most savage
moments ♪
♪ From "The Golden Girls" ♪
-Wait, I do like that.
-Man, hold up. How did you --
-♪ I'll take you down roads
that you never seen ♪
♪ Bitch, I'm the architect
of y'all's reality ♪
Well, here's an idea.
How about you two eat a meal
together?
-♪ Eating together but still
watching YouTube ♪
♪ A tuh mmrgha dah...YouTube ♪
[ Indistinct singing ]
♪♪
-[ Laughing maniacally ]